how much training do you do for your
health and well-being versus how much
was for
marathon training i used to train about
100 to 130 miles a week
so people often ask you you're a runner
you run every day and you're like well i
run 12 times a week after i retire for
about maybe like four or five months i
was still running like 10 miles a day
for six seven days a week so i'm like
what am i doing this for again and then
you have to kind of scale it down to
whether you want to run five miles or
four miles not feel guilty about it it
was very intense pretty intense to be
able to just be on the grind day in day
out and you know get ready for
competition get ready for
uh you know get into therapy or massage
or you always undergo because that time
crunch is important to do that first run
recover and eat and then do
re for the second run so it's constantly
thinking until you put your head in the
pillow you're constantly thinking what
can i do to better myself
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show very timely we have
meb keflesky
you might know him you might not if you
do it means that you probably run
he is an insanely accomplished runner he
won the boston marathon in 2014 he won
the new york city marathon in 2009 he
has a silver medal in the olympics in
2004 he went to ucla he has four ncaa
championships 22 national championships
was nominated for four olympic teams and
he's written two books so if you're into
running you've probably heard of meb
also it's really cool when they have
their bibs and their big time they
basically have their name on their bibs
so you've maybe seen him he comes from a
country called eritrea i mean it's just
a story of attrition it's a story i mean
what more parallel could you could you
make other than that story of attrition
and the fact that you have to have so
much attrition to run 26.2 miles for a
marathon um he just is a really good
human and has some really lovely stories
and some great perspectives on um on
just life itself and of course some
really good tips on running so
i hope you enjoy the show today i hope
you picked something up either
inspiration or perhaps some running tips
for your next marathon
okay
okay
okay
i'm wondering like where i've caught you
in uh your day because i heard you say
just well i know how much dedication you
have i mean the fact that you're 46 and
still
doing what
26 year olds maybe can do is insane
um but i know that you have a lot of
dedication and that your whole day
is
around rehab the training
um
you know the body and stretching and all
the things so like where have i caught
you at this moment today
today well you know i usually take my
daughters to my wife take the kids to
school and i just went for a little
exercise post retirement i'm tampa
florida and then uh spending some time
with you know people ask me what do you
do besides running or what's the other
hobby is spend time with family and
friends so i was just having a nice
coffee traditional eritrean ethiopian
coffee which is usually not a starbucks
30 minutes it's usually a couple hours
so
i'm at halfway mark and i said i gotta
go to go talk to the don and danica so
it's great
what has that transition been like for
you
the transition from retirement is great
to spend time with family and friends
but at the same time sometimes is with
so much into routines and goals and
um
tight schedule it's kind of like you
feel guilty
yeah to be like well i should be doing
this because when you're a runner
whether like you said earlier whether
you're doing therapy whether you're
doing massages whether you're doing
second run or crash training or
weightlifting and all that stuff your
mind is
taken away and you know whether you are
eating and what you gotta have to
prepare for or get ready for the next
day for the next week for the next month
or for the next race you're constantly
thinking but now it's like um you know
you were doing so many things now it's
kind of slowed down a little bit yeah do
you think it's been harder for you
um
physically or mentally to
i mean how much do you train now i guess
i mean his training now is just
your well-being as opposed to for a
specific goal which i'm actually curious
first off how much different is that
like
just for the for the regular human right
that goes
how much training do you do for your
health and well-being versus how much
was for
marathon training
you know danica this is kind of crazy
but i used to train about 100 to 130
miles a week
so people often ask you you're a runner
you run every day and you're like well i
run 12 times a week uh so that puts it
in perspective but now
as a retirement for health you know
after i retire for about maybe like four
or five months i was still running like
10 miles a day for six seven days a week
so i'm like what am i doing this for
again and then you have to kind of scale
it down to whether you want to run five
miles or four miles not feel guilty
about it because before it was like my
cooldown
after three mile warm-up a hard workout
and then a cool down sometimes i do
three miles four miles maybe five miles
so i can take the afternoon off to let
the bar recover now i'm running that
much you know what i used to do in
cooldown i'm doing it for my health so
it's kind of you know different because
it was very intense pretty intense to be
able to just be on the grind day in day
out and you know get ready for
competition get ready for uh you know
get into therapy or massage or you
always undergo because that time crunch
is important to do that first run
recover and eat and then do re for the
second run so it's constantly thinking
until you put your head in the pillow
you're constantly thinking what can i do
to better myself and especially when
sponsors and people are counting on you
you don't want to disappoint them
because you know you drive the car but
you know there's a team behind the team
and i run the 26.2 miles but there's a
team behind the team so you don't want
to disappoint them you want to give them
110 and sometimes it goes really well
and other times it doesn't because this
happens happen or mistakes happen and
but you should be grateful that you know
you put 110 percent so retirement now
for health is good because my mental is
difficult
physically is okay because i run four
five six miles i'm completely happy with
that what i was
five six days a week if i could do a
seven day body is health your body is
good with that but your mind is saying
your mind is like lazy
exactly you know sometimes you see
people you know for the first time in my
life you know people are doing kind of
more than i'm running they're like hey
i'm going to take the day off and not
feel guilty and then like i had a friend
in san diego she's like i'm not gonna
say who but two of us ran and this guy
did not run you know usually
the other way around saying hey can i
get a pacer on the bike or can i get
somebody to give me fluid and things
like that you're working very hard right
now it's like okay i need to be on a
chill mode and so mentally that
perspective has been different but also
i have to teach it kind of really
relearn how to calm down and not why not
because for my life for me as a being an
immigrant
you know education was important so when
i was at ucla until i get that ucla
degree i was
non-stop eight o'clock class for five
years just go go go go maybe i miss
three times or four times besides
traveling from classes so and now you're
gonna be a freshman athlete for 17 18
years that was intense to be able to
just be on the grind they end up because
we didn't have seasons you know it's not
like
four months and then you take off
business runners you're constantly in
the year round so you kind of feel like
a little bit of burnout so you got to
slow down and reteach yourself it's okay
to breathe it's okay to not be your mind
wander around the next and the next
thing yeah do you remember
where or what happened when you kind of
hit that spot because i think a lot of
people can relate to the fact that
there's change that doing something
differently for a lot of people might be
training more um you know
but it's just it's still a similar
challenge emotionally and mentally and
so what happened it was there like a
breaking point or a a moment that you
remember going okay something needs to
change and was there a breakdown or was
it possibly some kind of slow
progression
slow progression and i got to credit my
wife your donors and uh she just says
you know sometimes just gotta breathe
you know you you you have
you worked hard for the rest of your
life now you need to kind of chill but
then another person cassandra carr she's
part of the owner of the san antonio
spurs i remember she says retirement is
different
you just do something that you used to
enjoy it doesn't mean you stop doing
everything you know it just means you
got to find something passion that you
are you are excited about so i remember
i was in san antonio and having a hobby
my brother and manager he was there and
we were having at her house just kind of
relaxing having a tea and she says man
retirement is just doing something
different that you love and you didn't
have to stop just by now you can you can
go on your on your
schedule what you want to do versus
completely stop and if you just try to
completely stop it's not it's not great
for anybody you know it's not good for
for you mentally and physically but if
you do a little bit of something and a
little bit of another thing eventually
passion will take over
yeah i mean that makes sense it's like
anything and there's like uh even some
level of like uh an addiction almost to
it where you know you have to you don't
just i mean cold turkey's a little
dramatic and so you know having kind of
that fade in that new transition and
creating new habits is you know part of
the process of weaning off and sort of
shifting uh shifting your daily activity
so what were some things that you did
that you always wanted to do maybe it
was food maybe it was travel maybe it
was um i don't know drinking alcohol
because all i know is training for this
marathon i'm like you know in the last
like because the marathon's a couple
weeks away so um
i'm like i mean i have one glass of wine
now and i feel like i feel terrible from
it i feel like my recovery is horrible
my sleep is garbage like you know there
are things that you know really change
when you have that level of intensity of
doing something so i'm curious what
those things were that you thought about
maybe while you were training in in that
intensity that you thought man if i had
time or man if i didn't have to do this
in the morning
you know it's uh for me
getting up early in the morning you know
whether it was before flight or training
schedule you got to get that running
before going the next flight because it
might be to europe it might be time zone
changes and things like that so i said
you know people want to meet hey i'm
recently moved to florida a couple of
years ago they're like you want to meet
at 5 30 6 o'clock i'm like no
i don't want to i don't want to set an
alarm i did that for college i did that
for my workouts i don't want to do that
but some of that thing i have a sweet
tooth so i love having sweet tooth and
and you know now i don't you know when i
was my birthday i remember when i was at
mammoth lakes where i used to train in
california at altitude
my kids and wife used to have a fruit
cake for me you know i cannot have sugar
sugar because i was in the middle of the
season getting ready for so now i just
say i see dessert i'll have it maybe
twice or three times a day you know
i don't hold back but it's not to go
cold turkey also in terms of exercise
for me is
um
it's part of my life it's a lifestyle
for me you know it's not running was my
passion it was my career but at the same
time now i just go
run whenever i want to and then people
you know being a distance runner is
beautiful because you run into people
who appreciate what you have done and
they want to run whether it's 400 meter
or half a mile or a mile with you so if
you you know if you can keep up or
whatever it's fine
and if somebody wants to be competitive
they pass you and you want to get your
competitive spirit on it's like okay you
know it's time to move that speedometer
a little bit faster
i mean you guys are running at like a
sprinting pace i mean you know your
average per mile is like
what nobody runs one time so it's insane
so when you say 400 meters i'm like
laughing thinking that's not far and
then i was like wait a minute that might
be all i could last with you
so my only one
goal in my life as far as a bucket list
goes was to do a marathon that's all i
wanted to do was just do a marathon
and i don't know why that was it like
most people want to go somewhere you
know whatever but i wanted to punish
myself for 26.2 miles and so uh and
who's kidding i love the challenge i
love the mental challenge i love the
physical challenge i love having a goal
and training for something
um so i have a lot of questions about
this whole training thing because it's
crazy like
i thought to myself before
i could probably just because my mind is
really strong i could just go run it
like i could just go run a marathon i'm
not saying i'd be good at all but i
could go run 26.2 miles because my mind
is strong enough
and i'm and i almost didn't want to
train but then i was like okay fine
you've got this training schedule i'll
do it and it was about you know three or
so months long and um so let's start on
the macro level like was there ever a
lull and then we'll get a little bit
more finite because the people listening
that uh
you know are especially people i'm
there's gonna be a lot of people
listening that love running and they're
gonna get it and they've done a half or
they've done a full maybe
so this stuff is going to be so
interesting but from a macro level do
you ever take time off
in the year when you were in when you
were competing
uh i'm going to tell you this when you
run a marathon the next day is a force
with him out so you know
i hate to break it to you but you know
for us as you train you train your train
so intensely you know and when you run a
marathon your cross will be sore and
you're going to be in pain and then it's
like it's the first time out you know
and for me i take about a week off maybe
two weeks off depends how i recover and
then and then then gradually just start
walking but make sure you stretch and
things like that but yeah it's not a
season say like football basketball
season over and get them out it's like
spring marathon fall marathon and a lot
of races in between so the only time you
take time off is uh after the marathon
because wow
oh yeah no doubt okay good that's good
to know i'm literally thinking to myself
make sure you take a week off after
if meb takes a week off after i should
take a week off after because my mind
would probably tell me like four or five
days later i should probably do like a
like a flush run or something like i
should probably just kind of run like
three or four miles and just real easy
but i'm taking a week off thanks to you
um so then what was the actual amount of
time that was condensed down to
specifically for the marathon and i know
it's a little tough because like a lot
of people will just do a random marathon
and you know they have they need a lot
more training to prepare for that one so
you have kind of an all-year sort of
sort of con
conditioning but when you're getting
that that last little bit specifically
for a marathon how long does that last
for you
the marathon training yeah like right at
the end because you're always training
for a marathon
right right i mean people often say is
you need 16 weeks to train for a
marathon or 14 weeks of training for
marathon it all depends on the condition
of the person and somebody can pull it
out in eight weeks some people can pull
it out of six weeks it depends what
their previous
fitness was if somebody's driving from
scratch and then hey let's walk around
and whatnot and you could use the 12 to
16 weeks but i think for me
since i always been fit since college
collegiate years and professional and
the least amount i have done is eight
weeks and you know i was injured
recovered from the injury and then you
know you don't lose much you in terms of
fitness but mentally you lose a lot
because you're not
day in day out weekly you're doing not
doing the exercise so you're like you
have uncertainty can i make it can i
make it or i might be able to make it
but if you let the fitness come to you
great things happen positive thinking
whereas if he says oh i only got eight
weeks and panic attack i gotta run my
long run next week no you don't need to
do that let the long run be the
celebration of 26.2 miles now how do you
get whether you're doing five miles six
miles 12 mile 13 mile accumulation of
running getting to that race day without
been
setbacks or without being injured it's
gonna be okay but if he says you know
what i gotta get
five weeks out i got to do my 20 mile
run and you're only doing six seven
miles you you're mentally defeating
yourself already because you have this
perception but if he says hey i just
gotta be smart my previous condition is
whether i've done marathons or a half
marathon will carry me through this race
i just got to be healthy and be mind
focused and look at that day
that ultimate date of the marathon and
you'll be fine
yeah
what were some of the collection of
modalities that you would use to
stay sharp um i know you talk about
strength training and stretching and all
kinds of things like that like last
night i was thinking i was laughing as
i'm like you know researching and here
listening to you talk about things and
you were talking about doing stretching
after a run for a while and i'm like
laughing to my friend who ran her and i
ran 16 miles and i was like
we're not stretching aaron like like we
we should prob
meb stretches afterwards we don't we're
not even stretching we're just putting
ourselves in these sarah body boots um
so um so what what are the things that
you do that you would really attribute
to being like the foundation of your of
your of your ability to keep going
you know there was a great coach from
ucla john wooden he says it's not what
you're doing practice in two hours but
how you take care of yourself so the yes
the 60 miles training is checklisted but
hydration
is important normatec or compacts
electronics if you're feeling something
you'd rather just take care of it prehab
instead of rehab because you don't want
to wait until you get injured so you
have to think about the small thing that
says hey i'm in sync with this you know
at 16 miles i felt great now how can i
recover and whether it's tomorrow than
two days i can get a little bit running
so you have to do i use personally
generation you can as soon as i finish
my
my hard work out whether it's long run
intervals or tempo i have a packet of
you can uh with a 10 ounce of water that
that immediately is helping you recover
and then obviously the stretching is
important not many people do this but
it's five minutes of your stretching
that allows you not to get injured but
also helps you recover for tomorrow for
next day for next week but if you just
say hey we got that 60 mile run let's
just get on the car and go you already
got intense a little bit your hamstring
is tight your calves are tight or
achilles is tight then you're prone for
injury so the stretching is not 10 15 20
minutes about five minutes of stretching
the the core muscles that would help you
which means that like which ones are
those i mean for yeah
like
the quads the hamstring the calf the
achilles and or adapter and abductor and
those are the essentials you know you
know some people stretch their hands is
fine but the one that's going to carry
through 26.2 miles is out of the leg so
and the glutes the blues are very
important you know you want to be able
to just because you've been using the
same muscle for 16 miles the same pace
you want to change it up a little bit
stretching is you know when you're
watching tv or you're hanging out you
know comfortable with your friends or
family members it's okay to get on the
on the carpet and do a little bit of
stretching because you get ready for
36.2 miles at the boston marathon
there's a there's an excuse for it so
it's yeah it's just wonderful to be able
to do those small things but hydration
is important um while you eat obviously
60 mile run you know you need protein
now to be able to just help your body
recover from the shake and for me i i'm
a chicken and
beef kind of guy but some people are
fish or other plants like beans and
things like that whatever what was your
diet like i mean like what was your i
mean like i'm really curious your
overall you're talking about chicken and
beef and things like that but then even
just before too before you take the you
can during and after which i'm totally
gonna talk about could you break it down
into macros did you have like you know
30 percent
protein 30 carbohydrates um you know
40 fat or like how did it break down
general idea you have like yes you know
60 carbohydrate and 30 or so of protein
and then um you know 15 20 percent of
fat that you like to have but at the
same time depends when you do it so i'll
walk you through my my preparation the
night before i would go for a 60 mile
run on my long run i would like to have
spaghetti or
red sauce meatball would be good to have
and salad um if you don't have the if
you like pasta you can have rice brown
rice preferably and chicken or fish a
little bit but once you go you try that
in your long run you want to duplicate
that on race the day before the race as
well but the morning of a workout like a
long run or intervals or temples it's
very important for me i like to have um
bagels if i if i'm not at home if i'm at
home i like to have hambasha which is
homemade eritrea embrace like some of
the hawaiian bread i like to have put
almond butter or honey in it and i like
to have maybe half a banana just with a
little potassium i like to have
uh tea every day but unless i'm if i'm
doing intense workout then i'll have
coffee
good yes i feel like coffee that's a
great one to have and then during the
race um you know you have to get to know
your body a little bit you got to be on
science to be able just says you know
what
an hour before my workout i have to eat
or two and a half hours or whatever it
is because you don't want to have an
issue during the workout but for me it's
like two and a half hours or an hour and
a half i can get away with and then
during the race i would just have the
age of you can or electrolytes
every every
15 20k i would like to have that if i'm
doing a long run or tempo run um you
know temple run is race pace or a little
bit faster than race pace and long run
is kind of slower than race space just
you just their time on your feet is not
even the pace is not that important just
got to be time on my feet to get ready
for 26.2 miles so though
so tomorrow yesterday if you did your
long run i know i know you have great
support system and uh you know sometimes
on my long run 20 or longer sometimes
i'll go a minute per mile slower
and just time on your feet you just put
in the time on your feet and then the
tempos
be race pace or
a little faster you combine that with
the long run and the tempo around race
pace you're going to be fine for 26.2
miles oh god thank you you just put that
together that's where the tempo is where
you get the speed and then the long run
is it time on your feet is where you get
the distance and then they kind of merge
together i've been literally running
like every time i'm like well i wonder
if i can do like
sub nine for this whole time i run this
long run or i'm like you know it might
be a shorter run and i'm thinking to
myself can i you know run an 8 30 pace i
know don't laugh at my times um can i
run eight miles for this you know and so
anyway um wow gosh i i really made that
mistake and i wonder if other people do
too i i never really put that together
that the tempo is for the speed and the
time the distance was for the time and
they come together that's
yeah and then you know we have intervals
called intervals that you can be a
little bit repeats whether it's maybe
three times mile repeats a lot faster
than race pace like you're saying maybe
it's like a minute pace or 8 30 and one
night and start nine minute pace go to 8
45 and then 8 30 and then maybe finish
up an eight minute pace and guess what
with that
eight minute pace with the slower lower
long run maybe a ten minute pace or nine
and a half minute pace it comes together
to give you
eight ten eight fifteen or eight eight
forty yeah per mile and it comes
together this beautifully does and
especially when you know when you it's a
work of art when you put it all together
weekend without training and when you
have to do a beautiful 26.2 miles and
it's it's it's beautiful when it comes
together yeah i i mean
i i so the way that and then during is
like a thing you know so it's getting
that down and figuring out how often and
do you ever drink like you don't i'm
carrying like a bottle of water i've got
a packet with all kinds of like stuff in
it where i can pull out something that i
need um but um
but i i ended up learning that every
four miles was how often i would take
a you can and that seems to work for me
and i would just drink water generally
like every every mile i would take take
a big gulp
um so
how often did you was that and you can't
really it's great like i tried a few
others
and
it's so much easier to take and then i
got a technique down where i was like oh
you just roll it up and then it all goes
in pretty easily instead of trying to
hang on to it so there's like lots of
little things that go into the speed and
the transitions and the accessibility of
things so um how did you how do you
break it down in your race do you even
what do you take during race so i've
been a lead athlete i guess we have a
little bit of advantage because
special drinks are waiting for us every
5k uh so every three miles
ours
usually my ucan is waiting for me and i
would have
there's someone on the course for you
yeah sorry this one is a little
advantage you know
you're a pro
that's cool okay
and then is it a is it a cup or is it a
bottle so we have a regular water bottle
regular water bottle um that is already
mixed with our electrolyte in there um
every each table will have you know
there's about maybe 30 or 25 elite
athletes so
it'll be map table three first one under
on the table of three so every time
every 5k 10k 15 miles i look for table
three
and not first one on the table and
there's four or five points got to be
kind of coordinate like
this is if there's any similarities this
is where the racing
your racing comes in because you gotta
be able to just maneuver in a way hey i
gotta go to table three i gotta pick out
the first bottle and then after you get
that you got to get out of the way and
so a lot of uh mishaps can happen
a lot of passing a lot of cutting and
driving yeah and then people get a
little do people get a little shitty
like do they do they do that okay okay
that's part
shake my head for that one
and then you know some people will take
your drink because they miss their dogs
so you gotta
and no
yeah and i have missed my drinks or
somebody has taken and you gotta tap
them on the shoulder hey get you kind of
sprint and catch up to something hey
that's mine
i'll drink first if i have leftover you
can have it but other than that it's uh
that's the equivalent to like
time
that's the equivalent to taking someone
out right like you have to go like give
me that
yeah
yeah
it is hunting you out of the way
yeah i mean and and a lot of you know
tactically that's where tactics happen
so
and uh we call it fluid station and then
at that point you know some people will
get their fluid and they will spring so
this is where they sprint so they don't
allow you to drink they carry their
water for 400 meter or 500 meter sprint
while everybody's drinking because when
you're drinking you can't really swallow
it and they make that move and you know
spread and you know you when you have
digestion or whatever something's not
going
they spread and then eventually when
they come and slow down a little bit
when they want to they cannot drink so
yeah sometimes you have to be prepared
to just hold on your water carry for 400
meter quarter mile or even maybe half a
mile even so because if everybody's
surging you don't want to be
get stuck drinking and that stuff
happened when you're trying to go a lot
more faster than usual
yeah
so um
do you mix in uh so it's the
electrolytes do you take any of the
do you take any of the you can energy
packets like in the packet or or is it
already in the fluid so it marathoning
is an experience uh for me on the
beginning of my career i was having i
would i would tape it you know the gel
or whatever but now i use edge from you
can but you tape it and you can you know
use your mouse to kind of tear that
thing up and then
load a roll come into the in your mouth
and then you would have your fluid next
to it so you can you can
gap it down but i learned this from my
good friend ryan hall who was a great
runner and uh fellow teammate uh mammoth
lakes and also in the olympics he goes
why don't you just put it in in the pack
in the in the water bottle so made sense
you know i would put my uh
electrolyte or gel uh you can edge in
the in the water bottle and then when
you get to the 15k so i don't have every
water bottle with that i have
electrolytes and then i have caffeine or
age on
15 and 20 and 25 k just because if you
miss one you know if you miss 15 you
don't want to be until 40 to not have it
so you want to be able to just put it
next to each other
and then i would shake it just shake it
as much as i can before i could gulp and
then it kind of mixes and then you have
it all at once
um that's one of the things that i
learned later in my career but you know
it's you have to you know you have to
train with it obviously in in training
so kind of practice so because you don't
want to have it too often because you
don't want to have loaded stomach but
you want to have the right amount and
sometimes just put that edge you can in
it split the drink into two water
bottles instead of having it all at once
yeah
yeah so so you take little breaks during
the week you don't always consume it
it's like part of like really intense
training as opposed to regular training
absolutely yeah when the rigor is kind
of you're trying to duplicate what the
race gonna be in very intense so is that
you ever use real food do you ever use
real food in your mother's training
no no i have a friend of mine that
that in san diego that says that hey i
should just give you a lounge pouch
whatever it is so i can just do a
sandwich and
have a sandwich
when you know because for for us that's
why you use you can you know you get an
hour before the run and then i'm there
for 2 hours and 20 minutes or so i don't
need a lot to carry but i think to have
it and maybe 45 minutes before the gun
goes off it can carry you for two or
three hours
but no i never tried real food but it'll
be funny maybe as a retired athlete i
have to do that down the road oh the
sandwich can carry you for two or three
hours or the ucan edge can carry you for
two or three years
you can age can carry for two to three
well i feel like a real
i feel like a really amateur athlete
then because i take one every four miles
which is like every like 35 40 minutes
but you know you don't want to feel that
you know if that works for you is
everybody's different you know if you
have tried it and works for you stick
with it but eventually you know
hopefully we'll get you into this uh
community of running of marathoning
when you do the other one you can
experiment with it maybe do it every
5k every three miles and see how that
you know
take a good measure of the fluid you
know maybe six seven ounce uh when you
can at that 5k and then carry that to
10k and then 15k or every three miles
that can you know kind of inside
will help you i think tremendously yeah
wow fascinating i'm learning so much
into how to become a professional runner
um in the meantime i'm just going to
carry all my things with me in a little
packet when you came across the you can
products uh what i mean what was it
about them and and what made you partner
with someone like you can
you know i got interested as you can in
2009 and dr christa austin is the one
that introduced me to it i'm a dietitian
and uh exercise physiologist and i
remember you know just hearing the
the name you can you know and to be able
to win the university marathon you can
put your mind to whatever you want and
it was just an incredible name but also
and then i said let me try it out i'll
always try the product and see if i
agree with me and i like to have it and
you know the story behind jonah how it
started with the family fellow man and
now his parents have to wake him up
every two to three hours to feed them
because of glycogen storage and i want
my heart and to be able to you know
that's how it started and then i became
the first athlete to sign and it was
just you know it wasn't even the
superstructure was amazing i think when
i went to new york i was traveling a lot
but making a lot of appearances and i
wasn't running a lot but you know i was
thinking that you can't shake and people
said you know how many miles are you
running you're looking fit and strong
and you know i think it was just
timing of it i was able to help me be
lean and strong and consistent
energy and ever since you know i never
never looked back uh i used the edge i
also use the
shake afterward and three times a week
you know intervals tempos and long run
it's the first thing with my system and
has done the longevity has given me is
that my secret weapon with you can just
be able to just share it with it with
others now if you haven't tried it's the
time to try it to help you be the best
that you can and i feel fortunate to be
working not only with this the company
but the the partnership and
uh support that i have gotten from the
whole family the community of ucan is
amazing
yeah amazing it's just magic when
something finally works and especially
on top of it when you find a company
that you know has integrity and purpose
it's like a match made in heaven
absolutely
and i feel that way for you ken it's
just it's just been you know just you
know you know if the word goes around
and you hear it you know but part of the
sport is hey i'm i travel you can and
that's you know it's working because
it's not like you
you endorse it and you didn't hear about
it but being a distance runner is like
hey meg i want to meet you because you
can't has worked for me you know i used
to have gi problem but now i use you
can't i'm good with it and hey what is
what is the you know what how else do
you use it and it's just wonderful you
know hopefully you know when we're in
boston we started with 20 20 people at
the you know in 2010 now we've got you
know 400 500 people knowing about it and
sharing the running community
and and i heard you've been using it so
it's incredible to be able to see uh
people use it and and i you know it's
just a wonderful product and the people
that are sustained with it is just also
incredibly important so uh then the
strength training i think is maybe the
other aspect because i mean for myself i
remember i was doing an 18 mile training
run and
i had done some deadlifting and you know
you know basically like a lot of
posterior work glutes and hamstrings a
few days before the run and i was still
a little sore and i went running and i
mean that another another thing i want
to ask about is heat because i'm i live
in arizona so scottsdale is very hot and
so i was running at like six to nine a.m
6 30 to 9 30 in the morning and i know i
know you're so fast um but i you know
it's very hot here so i mean i wear
actually it's you can see the tan line
probably from my my watch but i wear a
garmin and you know it was peaking at
like 109 degrees and so you know between
having posterior soreness from strength
training as well as then the heat which
those are two separate things um it was
a it was a disaster strength training is
important you know obviously you know
the ligaments and the muscles need to be
strengthened to carry you 13.1 miles or
26.2 miles and you know you just got to
be
just like a strategy race you got to
strategize want to do them also because
you don't want to do them after you do a
60 mile run or you know on the easy days
you want to be able to do it you know
sometimes you got to change your long
runs or your intensity because you did
not feel like you were up to it or happy
to get the best out of yourself so that
means if the training core training is
the next day you don't want to do the
long run or intervals and then go stick
to that routine you have to be flexible
to be able to change but you know as
much as you know weight your body weight
is good or the bars you just want to get
those muscles
kind of limbery and really um
cancel up a little bit to be able to
help you carry the carry the duration i
think i'm you know the
dyna disc or what the medicine ball is
important doing the curls or hamstring
curls and the and the medicine ball is
very important to instead of going to a
gym and be able to
lift big weights because you know 26.2
miles is a long ways but at the same
time you want to be able to just nurture
those muscles as healthy as possible and
you know doing a fun way you know and
the push-ups suit up score importance
very important i mean i can hear stay
here and talk to you all about that
stuff but i have a
book called methylmortals that tells you
all about the strength training and
conditioning and crash training because
as a distance runners we cannot
sometimes we are prone to injuries and
you have to prevent it if it becomes big
problems so taking a day off going for a
swim or taking a day off or going an
elliptical ride is important those
things instead of hey it's on my
schedule i gotta do it don't try to be
to the book you know as much as he can
you try to but at the same time if you
have to know what is best for danica to
be able to say you know what coach or
team i need to take a day off today
because thanks to now i just leave water
last night so that 16 mile run we're
gonna do tomorrow or the next day versus
say forcing it and sticking rigid to it
it can it can
prone to be a little bit of a problem so
you gotta be flexible but at the same
time strength training is just important
to be able to get to your posture you
know i don't know if you wear sunglasses
but uh you should
you gotta wear your glasses hopefully
during the during the run as well so
that way because we get fatigue i use my
maui gym to be able to just when i'm
running because when you fatigue your
head goes down but if you have
sunglasses
this for the whole time so it won't slip
so that's another damn teacher that i'm
sharing with you
oh man
actually that was something witnessed is
that i kind of run a little like chest
down and i i
i really try to concentrate on that
after it was pointed out um but i don't
wear sunglasses and i and i probably
will wear a hat but i actually i mean
i'd never wear a hat either my eyes are
not very sensitive and so i think to
myself i don't really squint that much
but it is probably some level of a drain
and it's also a little bit of a it's
like a
it's almost like wearing some you know
people will tape their bodies in areas
that are sore like reminds you to have
the right sort of posture as you said so
interesting i don't know if i'll wear
sunglasses because i'm almost down to
the wire
and i don't know which ones wouldn't
bother me but in the future if i were to
ever do a marathon again i will train
with sunglasses for that
that um body position reason that's a
that's a great one
um you know even though you know you
don't wear glasses but you gotta con
constantly thinking you know shake their
hands like you know just let them loose
every
5k or every four mile just let you know
because you know you're running like
this just let them down the block will
come in but also
thinking about you know wearing
sunglasses about to say how's my posture
you gotta think okay how's my posture am
i staying tall you know just imagine you
have an egg on top of your head you
don't want to tilt it whatever you just
want to be tall and that's going to help
you just do that maybe every
10k or something they don't have to do
it four or five times and that's when
you'll be okay
i mean you you have so many different
modalities you became such a you know
insanely accomplished highly tuned
athlete and you took it so seriously
but i want to go back to
how you got that way
and
you know hearing your story about uh
growing up in
uh atreya and
living by living without your family
from five to ten years old and then
moving to italy i mean you've had quite
a path and i i'm wondering like first
off what do you what is your family like
how did how did that go so you got
separated at five years old and and did
you did you get were you back together
with them when when you were 10
and uh thanks for bringing that up with
danica and in around to overcome my
autobiography i discuss about how i was
born in eritrea and my dad has to flee
from eritrea to sudan because he was
wanted by the ethiopian soldier so he
was going to get prison or kill so my
mom has to kind of have a hard talk just
tell him hey you might want to take this
chance you know it's not like you get on
flight but he has to go over 225 miles
in the wilderness and sometimes he has
to spend the night and the trees on top
of the tree in the branch because you
know you know if he's on the ground
there's hyenas lions scorpions and other
animals that can take his life so he
survived it but uh you know my
my parents had five kids and one on the
way and they tell them to say if it's if
there's a girl call her the internet or
if it's a guy calling the
girl call it amina which it means would
believe that one day if i make it a safe
land i would look after you so i did not
see my father from the age of five till
i was 10 and my mom and i brothers and
sisters grew up in a third world country
not literally no running water where we
have to fetch the woods to have fire so
we can cook meals and we've got two to
three miles to get that and in fact one
day i was in the vicinity of another
border and i got caught unfortunately
and uh trying to get as much uh
uh woods like as i can and i got caught
and my you know we have to spend the
whole day there and my mom has to come
and bail us out with that about a water
bottle size of grain to
like a bail bond almost would allow us
to escape and then you gotta go two to
three miles to go to get to the water
out of the well and you know carry it on
yourself or put it on a donkey to be
able to do that so but fortunately my
dad made it and we didn't see him for
five years and there was great people
who helped us escape from eritrea um dr
brendichi uh his boss and later michael
who's my my sister ruth's mom i have
half sister ruth and they work together
to be able to escape and i remember
there's so many generosity people in the
world and my dad asked his boss if he
could learn them this in 1986 if he
could lend him a 10 10 million lyric
italian italian money at the time was
six thousand u.s dollars and he says is
that to save some one one person or to
save everybody and my dad said you know
with the money that i have and worked it
would save everybody and dr brendich his
boss said come back wednesday and he
came back on wednesday and he gave him
10 million liter cash and he says this
is not alone it's a gift that's how we
got saved and
that's how we made it to from eritrea to
italy and we lived in italy for a year
and a half and
i saw tv for the first time
as a 10 year old i did not understand
how people fit in that side that tv so i
went behind the tv to see if they were
there and
that's
humble beginning but you know
fortunately we came to the united states
on october 21st 1987 and uh we worked
hard and you know we were however then
i was 12th grade i'm sorry 12th year old
in seventh grade so my oldest brother
had the most difficult because he was
placed without we didn't speak english
so we were just placed by our age we
didn't have any my brothers had a little
bit more education than i did but
so you are 15 years old you're gonna be
in uh ninth grade or you're 12 year old
yourself was in seventh grade but they
luckily for me they put me in elementary
for one year just i can learn english
and the following year in 201988
i was uh in p-class uh in san diego next
to the san diego zoo if you ever there
check it out roosevelt junior high
middle school and then he said if you
run hard you're going to get a or b make
sure you take the smile run seriously he
told the whole class and my parents
always expected an a for them class and
i have two older brothers who ran for
roosevelt junior high and they had the
roosevelt roosevelt junior high club
shirt and i want to be like them and so
when the push says go i just ran as hard
as i can it wasn't on the track four
times it was around the baseball field
around the software field and then go to
the middle of the campus down the ramp
and finish up the ramp and uh to get the
tissue and a to get the t-shirt and i
have to run
6 15 i end up running 520 and he goes
he can't believe it he's like
he called the high school coach and uh
he says this guy is going to go to the
olympics he said you're going to go to
the olympic but i'm like um did i get a
t-shirt yeah
do i get a t-shirt yeah i don't know
what the word olympic meant i'm just
really learning my english so i have no
idea and i went ask my dad that evening
and says what's the olympics and he said
what'd you do what happened it's like uh
of course duke lord says i ran i'm gonna
go to the olympics in my native tongue
obviously and he goes well the olympics
are every four years and they guess
peace and harmony different continents
and countries get together for a
friendly competition
and the rest is history
after that i got my t-shirt my a and i
started making friends high-fiving
people and you know my picture was in
the gym and uh you know they said i was
known as a faster seventh grader
that would be a fact do you think
that
when your teacher said
if you run fast you get an a
that that was
planting some kind of seed within you
absolutely yeah i mean it says i'm i i
believe given 110 percent every time in
each time and my parents expect the same
thing in school they won't say hey this
is the land of opportunity make sure you
work hard in fact my dad will cause
about 4 30 a.m before 7 30 o'clock clock
on weekdays to learn english as a
dictionary so yeah i want to get that i
badly because my parents said so and
then when coach dukler said you're going
to get an a i said what i need to do and
i want to run as fast as i can and try
to hit aim for that 6 15 but i surprised
myself and his expectation as well and
and uh you know when he saw that in his
clock he couldn't believe it he's like
he called the high school immediate like
this little one is really good
and uh you know that's how i was
introduced to to get an a or t-shirt but
at the same time i feel that's when my
god-given talent was discovered and
after that i never looked back and i
think sports is great to be able to give
you confidence and you know give you
camaraderie and then also the friendship
that you make i was very shy and timid
kid and that kind of breaks that shell
for me was that your moment or was that
the moment other people knew do you
remember when it hit you that you're
like
i'm good at this
yeah i mean i think you know
definitely help others kind of make
friends i guess you say you know give
you high fives on when you're going from
one campus to another but for me that
was like
a
boost of confidence it's like oh
this is this was fun you know i was not
like i never do this one again it was
just like this is cool and you know the
easiest a i ever got
and and the rest is you know i was able
to just carry on that and then you know
it had helped that two oldest brothers
ran for that school and then for san
diego high and then i'm like oh when i
was in eighth grade they were on the
cross country team i'm like well there's
a picture of me behind the tree just
kind of like oh maybe one day i'll be
there with them yeah exactly so kind of
observing and then
it just kind of built up on that seventh
grade and then eighth grade and the
ninth grade i was able to join them for
the crosstalk team and i was honored to
make the team and then you know other
brothers and sisters we were able to win
the san diego section and then advance
to the state so kind of kind of build
builds up build up and build out to be a
great journey for all of us
oh so you guys probably ran together you
trained together then yeah
yeah so it was 12th grader and a
sophomore and a freshman uh but
we didn't know training that much so
whenever the team got together we ran
but we we did not train on our own
well you didn't need to
it's probably good you didn't have to
wear your body out at that age you know
you got to sort of run when you needed
to and it was already
winning tournaments and meets for you
i'm sure
what was it like for your brother you
said you have two brothers
i have two older brothers and then i
have three other brothers um one of the
ten brothers and sisters
so for the brothers that also ran and
that were on the team at roosevelt um
i mean how did how did it go because you
came and became a big star and you went
on to ucla and you know did they go on
to college were they running for college
and you know how has that been you know
i mean i'm i'm kind of curious uh you
know i have a sister and you know i know
how it went and i know how amazing my
sister is but it's still success
especially if somebody else is kind of
involved can be
tricky
yeah i mean i think they're uh it was
great to be with them and then my oldest
brother futsom he ended up going to uc
san diego and he ran for them so he
i started when i was seventh grade he
started when he was like nine maybe even
sophomore when he was sophomore in high
school so he didn't have the proper
training and he was more prone to
injuries because for some of those other
teammates they've been running for six
years four years or what not so when he
went to ucsd he was the seventh man on
the team and then by the end of the
season he was the second from seventh to
second place on the team so he was very
proud of that and then eventually had an
acl tear and played soccer and that let
that go and then my middle brother
all those brothers futsum and atlu he
was kind of like um
you know a mentor for me because he was
closer in age and then sometimes we
would go for a run if we did for warm up
for soccer practice kind of something's
like you can't breathe so hard if you
breathe hard you're telling your
competitors you are tired so you gotta
breathe deeper and kind of not make
notice so but training with him was uh
in high school was fun and be able to
you know he was the guy and number one
guy in the team as a fresh he was a
sophomore i was a freshman and then he
was goofing around a little bit with a
bike riding somebody else's bike and he
fell and hurt his hip and then i took
over and then
after that i became the number one guy
and he became the number two guy but
eventually he did the
800 who you know he did really when the
800 and then he still his passion was
soccer but he did whatever he could to
run and to help the team but uh you know
he's they're they're happy for me and
then my oldest brother and
younger brother went to sydney australia
on my first olympic team my brother goes
he had because like i said i don't know
what olympic was and for him now he's
you know he's graduated college and then
he's in sydney australia at the olympics
he says if i was if i knew i had any
idea this was the olympic i would have
kept running so he did not know the
information but we were all talented you
know equally talented or if not you know
futson was actually probably a little
bit more talented but he was more prone
to injury so you went to ucla what what
did you go for
you know i when i went to ucla i was
under coach bob larson but it was one of
the most diverse school that i think
public school that was there and it was
the number one athletic and academic
combination school so
i don't want to be another athlete who
never got the diploma so the pressure
for me to get my ucla degree was huge on
me and my family and even my mom at one
point is because i was running more
miles now i was getting skinnier so like
you know you should stop this running
thing because you know you're getting
tired you should just get a job like
your brothers that on a desk but i said
mom it's paying for my education but i
also love it you know and then
eventually i started communication with
business and then once i graduated in
1999 i became professional and then
start competing and
you know what a thrill of a lifetime to
graduate from ucla and i said now i can
give running a full priority because
definitely did not take prior to when i
was at ucla academics did and
and then you know i did after the
training and uh started doing that and
then also
going to sydney australia just to wear
the red white and blue uh singlet it
means so much for me for the country
that gave me opportunities to to be the
best that i can since i was the age of
12. and it was a kind of pinch yourself
you know this is a dream come true so it
was a it was a blessing and i
i i wasn't stayed in the village and i
got the flu that was going around i was
i was not in my hundred percent and you
know when you're so fit you're more
prone to get sickness and injury but i
finished 12 they had a prelim for the
10k six point tomorrow with the prelim
for it i was the second last guy to
qualify and i finished the race um 12th
place i was so happy and my dad was
there you know my mom was there my my
brothers were there and like my dad is
like this is the dream come true for
america for america i know you're going
to win tonight son i'm like dad
i have not broken 28 minutes the guys
that i'm competing against they're
running 26 30 i'm like i hope i don't
get laughed you know plus i'm sick but
he was a little bit disappointed so you
got to think positive you know but i
said that
you know highly good wrestling from
ethiopia together from kenya those guys
are a minute and a half faster than i am
but i hope to give my best shot and i
did i finished 12 but before i left the
stadium i said i'm happy to represent
our country
and the olympics but next time around i
hope to make the team and also win a
medal for our country and you know in
2004 uh i had i hadn't made the 10k team
and the marathon but the marathon such a
it won the history over me because my
chances of meddling was better than the
10k because i was a national champion
american record holder in the 10k
whereas in the marathon this is my
fourth marathon i was the 39th fastest
guy in the field the chances were not
pretty but to be in athens greece where
the olympics started where the marathon
got its name from and to you know to be
a hot hilly and humid
uh challenging circumstance i think it's
not going to favor world records so i
said you know what i got to put my grit
down and
do the proper training and we worked
hard with dina caster who was the female
runner who got bronze medal and her
coach jovi hill coach joe vigil and my
coach bob larson we kind of secluded
ourselves in mammoth lakes and train
hard and
to be able to go to athens and be able
to you know win two medals for for our
country and win a silver medal for me
where i met my dad the first time in
five years in athens greece before going
to italy to be able to be there and win
that medal meant so much to me wow
wow
where do your parents are your parents
still alive
fortunately yes my parents are still
alive and they're in san diego
california where i grew up
and yeah they're they're blessed you
know we always celebrate october october
21st through call phone calls or
uh
because that was the rebirth of our
family you know and when we first came
to the united states i will never forget
that day you know um october 21st 1987
coming up now and
you know 34 years almost so it's uh it's
a blessing and
you know whenever i get the opportunity
to spend time with them it's always a
joyful moment
yeah yeah do you um
i feel like you you're
you have intention you have depth and
you have integrity
um i'm wondering
you know
where do you get that from and is
religion or spirituality a part of your
life
um was that was that ever a part of your
life
oh absolutely
greek orthodox is what i was raised and
be able to just i know been an immigrant
and it was not we were not going to
church as much because we were locations
to the location to different locations
but
i was baptized when i was four years 40
days old and and be able to just kind of
believe in god and my my dad always said
you know when he was in that journey of
225 miles
he was gun point at one point but the
gun never went off so he says
if god
it wasn't in my life that would be the
end of it but he feels to that this day
you know my journey to make that and
survive
there's a higher power in god to allow
us the life that we have and
you know for us when we're very the
fortunate ones that have come out of
third world country and make a living
for our life but we know better than
anybody or anybody we just feel very
fortunate that god has given out this
mercy this journey and us to be
faithful and and believers to be able to
be the best that we can but yeah it's
important to uh
understand where you came from for me i
go back to eritrea and after i did my
first marathon in new york in 2002 i
went to eritrea to see to see for the
first time and kind of remember a little
bit when i was
10 years old but you know you kind of
forget sometimes where you came from and
when i went back to see that i was able
to uh
relive a little bit you know how people
were surviving no electricity no running
water uh they got to go
you know and complaining about my last
40 minutes of the marathon was kind of
small scale versus people are from
sunrise to sunset they're working
diligently and for me it was just two
hours three hours of hard work which
nobody forced me to do i enjoyed doing
it and it was my profession so to look
back gives you strength to what you
could potentially do because
you are grateful for those opportunities
you know uh you asked me earlier you
know in 2008 was i had a big
big mishap you know after winning silver
medal in athens after getting second in
new york 70 days later third in boston
you're like i'm ready for another win
you know which marathon i'm going to win
but you don't always get what you think
you deserve and i had a
2008
november of 2007 the trials were in new
york city marathon where i had made a
name for myself and
unfortunately you know my good friend
ryan shea passed away for having cardiac
arrest and i finished eighth in the race
so it was just like and i learned after
the finish that my good friend has
passed away i just kind of went to the
ground and couldn't get back up
people lift me up i couldn't walk i was
on my knees and elbows crawling like a
10 month old baby because i don't fall
but it was just but eventually 10 weeks
later we realized that i have perfect
stretch fracture and because when life
is taken away from you injury is the
smallest part of that
element and uh i kind of put it two
together and i say you know what but
somehow someway you have to move forward
when things get challenging and
circumstances are hard on you and i just
remember
believing and also praying with my wife
and my brother i said
i know what i did in training did not
exemplify the results i wanted to hear
because my wife is like when she saw me
on my knees and elbows moving from one
place to another in the hotel she's like
this is not a way to make a living you
having a college degree i got my college
degree we got to do something else i
said well faith god has something if
that's god says this is it i'm okay with
it i have my silver medal to prove it
and i'm not to prove anything else i'm
completely happy but i knew down deep
there was more that i could do and you
know i said my olympics will be the new
york city marathon i can't wait another
four years and to be able to just run
the new york marathon wearing that usa
jersey and be able to win it and a
personal record time is you know is
there's hope if there's hope and there's
faith and amazing things can happen
don't give up in the moment you know
just believe in yourself believe in your
team and great things are waiting for
you
do you have a mantra or something that
you say to yourself when things are hard
yeah i usually say i pray uh but i also
say run to win which means getting the
best out of yourself you know sometimes
you everybody's hurting when you're
running 26 going to miles you're going
to struggle at one point another but you
know that so you got to say okay the
beauty of running is okay let's scale
back a little bit to you know if you're
going
9 45 or 9 30 pace it's okay let's go
through that you know 9 50 and get it
back and then we want to go finish at 9
30. you know you have to have those
internal dialogue within yourself and
your team so for me sometimes i pray you
know when i was running the 20 then 2012
olympic games i was ready to drop the
towel i was really struggling
i was 30 37 years old and i thought it
was my last olympics i was
at 21st place with the at the halfway
mark and my goal was to win top three or
personal or best and i know what's going
to happen so i'm like you know what
this church looks a good place to drop
out but then i realized looking down i
said i have that usa jersey how many
people would love to be in my shoes and
i came positive thinking i prayed i said
god let me let me get a second group you
know again second group and then just
running with them he said maybe i could
be one of those guys and then eventually
from 21st place i'm in 15th i'm in 10th
and with 5k to go i was in sixth place
my coach pointed out six fingers i'm
like
wow this is you know and you're barely
trying to finish this as you're
presenting your counter keep going and
you know amazingly you don't know what
happens sometimes people get drug tested
and they test positive not in the moment
but down the road and i said i got to
get out fourth place and i remember the
santos my friend from new york from
brazil who run new york he was with me
now with a 500 meter to go i have to
pass them but i said good job the santos
bound in my mind i'm thinking go past
him as fast as he can
and i kind of see the our flag on the
left side should i grab the flag or
should i not because he's trying to
chase me down and i grab the flag and
came in fourth place so be in the moment
and and say run to win getting the best
out of yourself sometimes even though
you feel
given up
if you're not injured or medically
wounded just stay with it because bother
things it will teach you more about
yourself and how to overcome adversity
in those situations what you can do when
things go perfectly even though
sometimes you struggle to the finish
line
that's good advice
do you
have or feel
like you have a certain purpose like an
overlying
life purpose a message
something that you want to show people
do accomplish have make peace with
you feel a sense of purpose for
something specific
i'm a believer and obviously god has a
purpose for me on this earth and that
our purpose is to influence people to
run it and i
uh i wish i could say that when i was in
seventh grade i wish i could see that
when i want for ncaa titles or break an
american record but the greatest purpose
for me on the earth was
on
april 21st 2014 uh when i ran the boston
marathon you know as you know i won the
boston marathon but a year prior to that
something was taken away from all of us
mentally physically and some
human being that we could never get back
but um i was there i missed that bombing
by five minutes because i was watching
my fellow runners for four hours plus
because i never get this opportunity to
do that i love seeing people run i enjoy
it immensely and i left because i had an
appointment and the bombing happened and
as soon as i got to the fairmont couple
which is not too far away and
i remember
um
bonnie ford from espn.com she asked me
are you scared to bring your family
that same evening or are you gonna come
back or what is where are you right now
and i remember telling her i hope to be
healthy enough to win it for the people
i remember saying that that afternoon
and for 365 days you have that conscious
you have to live with when you see the
boston strong or when you see the red
sox doing something or
you know you know t-shirt or hat and
things like that when you travel around
the country you see that it's like
you're praying say god help me that day
hopefully to win and i remember when the
red sox put the finish line that trophy
the world series at the finish line i
was getting worked on therapy i remember
to my
therapist saying i hope to do that
win for the boston on pictures today and
so my purpose to answer your question
did come true and this is uh to be
influential in terms of sports and to be
there for our runners and to be able to
consciously something my spirit told me
to write the victim's name
on the bib that i wore the night before
and and to be able to just go it went
viral because i i wrote crystal sean
martin and ling i might i know those
other four victims that we lost through
the vomit and the limbs and others
mentally physically that we have lost is
irreplaceable but i feel fortunate
enough to be able to tell my story and
be able to carry their names and give a
little bit of a hope and that's my
purpose to give a little hope for people
to get the best out of themselves
you've done that through your whole life
i mean look at where you look at where
you came from and look at what you've
accomplished do you um
coming back around to uh to the boston
marathon in particular all right like do
you have some final advice for me for
all the runners really i mean this is
for anybody who runs marathons this is
applicable but um you know something to
think about a mindset certain things
that you've mishapped along the way that
learn for yourself when you were younger
i mean hit me what do i need to know
what's some good advice
marathon is a metaphor for life patience
is a virtue and boston is a test for
marathoning i know you haven't done any
other marathons or for those of you that
are doing marathons for the first time
boston is a
challenging course but we get excited we
guess a narrow road at the beginning and
i made that mistake my first marathon i
went out fast and kind of said what did
i do that for
so what you want to do is in the
marathon if you can make it your last
mile the fastest you're going to have a
great time you're going to enjoy it and
the friendship especially after what
we've been through for the with the
pandemic and other things you know this
is a celebration 26.2 miles is a
celebration the hard work is done now uh
paper is is the net
where you kind of right not as much just
kind of be healthy be mentally
physically and spiritually in the same
page and say hey i'm going to go out
there and have fun and have a good time
with the people that are running there
because
that's the beauty of of running you know
you just enjoy each other and
and palestinians know their sports you
know with all the support they have but
on patreon stay there they understand
the big celebration from hopkinton to
boston is on so they're going to have a
great appreciation and uh i think it's
wonderful that you know we get to run
again and because you know
they've been uh you know consolation in
the past so this is
we've been injured or wounded now we
come alive too and we don't take
anything for granted just be able to
appreciate it and
you know we we all have worked hard but
now the celebration becomes and i want
to wish you the best on all the runners
because
marathon should do once in your lifetime
after that it becomes optional so i'm so
happy for you that that's out of your
bucket list but hopefully we will hook
you up into this marathon thing or have
marathons and it's a great community
it is i i have i i do feel that we're
there's a because i'm running for
charity so there's a there's a group for
the charity and you know there's a bunch
of us on a text thread where we send
messages back and forth and then my
sister's running it as well as well as
my very good friend aaron who um i've
worked out with for many years and so
you know we the three of us have texted
a lot about things so i think you're
right and the metaphor for life it's so
true there's so much micro macro to look
at i was telling my friend when we were
running our 16 miles the other day i
said you know in our whole training
there's been like pigs peaks and valleys
and times where you have something go
wrong and that's just you know those
were macro for the like we're going to
get to the marathon and if we don't have
something happen within those 26.2 miles
that hits a peak or a valley or
something like that and we need each
other i will be shocked so i think
that's an incredible perspective on it
and i think that as far as
i know that as far as your purpose goes
you you have been living that you have
been living that example of um
showing people what is possible and
having faith and
i'm grateful for that so many people are
so thank you so much for your time and
congratulations on just
you know millions of miles of proving to
people what is possible by the human
body and spirit
thank you so much danika it means a lot
and uh you know right for charity is
important because we've been very
fortunate to be in a pedestal or have
the big honor and responsibility to do
things for others and for me you know i
ran for the team four kids in new york
and i ran from martin richards
foundation to eight year old boy in
boston and that was a thrill of a
lifetime and you know i have my own
foundation and my foundation that i
would like to run sometime and uh you
know
i love to help others compete and why
not so if you are up for another
marathon i might hit you up on it oh man
okay that's um don't do that to me i'm
so competitive and so like oh man don't
worry you got a personal best waiting
for you on october 11
oh that's a fact it's by default but
that's true that is still true
all right well i'll you know i will say
that half's seem like a no big deal
right like a half seems like right now
after 16 yesterday yeah i could probably
go out and run 13 miles sure um but uh
you know we'll see about that we'll see
we'll see about that 26.2 i mean it's
fine you'll be fine you'll have a great
time
all right well thank you so much and
congratulations on just having an
amazing life
thank you so much congratulations on
your wonderful illustrious career and
keep going and then to be able to do
this in the marathon welcome to the
running community and looking forward to
seeing you on
october 11th i'll be there i think we
will see you i think there's some lunch
or something i heard about so i'm gonna
come over and say hi if that's okay
awesome
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button